ever wonder what members of an elite scp  foundation mobile task force secretly  desire foundation researchers snapped a  picture of a member of mobile task force  beta 7 maz hatters using scp-978 the  desire camera while they were standing  in casual clothing with a neutral  expression and this was the result the  room is much cleaner nothing much  changed in the photo aside from the  cleanliness of the room it seems that  the subject's desires were simple and  extremely achievable which makes sense  given that the mass hatters specialize  in the cleanup of toxic waste a member  of the cleaning staff was promptly  brought in to tidy up the space and for  once the desire reflected by scp-978 was  actually realized